what happened during tolkien's second
age of middle-earth that has led the
creative minds at amazon to explore this
era during their lord of the rings
series
let's dive into this little disgust saga
a second age implies that there was a
first age that came before it
and tolkien's first age is the primary
subject of his book
the silmarillion the book focuses on the
adventures and tragedies of the elves in
their epic wars with the dark lord
morgoth after centuries of bloodshed
morgoth is finally defeated in the
earth-shattering war of
wrath the event is action-packed with
tons of dragons eagles orcs elves men
and even a bunch of balrogs and other
supernatural creatures to boot
when all is said and done the survivors
on both sides flee
most of the elves head west to the same
heavenly land that frodo and bilbo
sailed toward at the end of the return
of the king
however a few of the elves along with
the men dwarves and
any surviving baddies head further into
middle earth
which is where the second age picks up
while amazon won't be exploring the
first age
there's no doubt that it will be an
important backdrop as the show unfolds
the second age begins with a bunch of
refugees looking for new homes
and while there are too many stories of
settling here in kingdom building there
to explain them all in detail
a few of these new settlements are worth
noting first
is meathland a port settled by elves in
the first year of the second
age the harbor is located on the
northwestern shores of the continent and
it becomes middle earth's primary
connection to the forgotten west
fans of the films will recognize
meathland by its more commonly known
title
of the grey havens the same spot where
frodo and bilbo eventually head out to
sea
in ring bearing retirement i think i'm
quite ready for another adventure
almost 1700 years after the grey havens
is built
the elvish stronghold rivendell is
founded by everyone's favorite counselor
elrond this time the settling takes
place by necessity
after elrond has a nasty run-in with
sauron
also known as imladris and the last
homely house
east of the sea rivendale will stand as
one of the chief
bastions of protection for the free
people of middle-earth throughout the
rest of the second and third ages
and it will go on to feature prominently
in the lord of the rings and hobbit
stories
one of the first casting leaks for
amazon series was morphed clark
who was slated to play a younger version
of the elven lady galadriel
this brings up the intriguing question
of what galadriel was up to
several thousand years before she shows
frodo her mirror
and spazzes out when he offers her the
one ring
[Music]
she may look young but galadriel is one
of the oldest beings in all of middle
earth
by the time of the second age she's
already thousands of years old and
married to her
husband keleborn the lord and lady
bounce around
living with various elvish communities
throughout the entire second age
while the specifics of their story can
get a bit confusing
eventually they cross the misty
mountains and relocate to lothlorien
but not as its rulers the elvish power
couple continues to have a heavy
influence on the affairs of the age
and galadriel is eventually given her
own elven ring
which she uses to keep her new home safe
and prosperous
at some point she also gives birth to
their daughter calebrion
who becomes the wife of elrond and the
mother of arwen
while galadriel and kelleborne's time to
truly shine
won't come until the third age there's
no doubt
there's some of the primary movers and
shakers of the second age as well
so far we've talked a lot about elvish
events but the second age is actually
mostly focused on the affairs of men
while men have been around for quite a
while by this point
there's one kingdom in particular that
really defines the second age
the island nation of numenor after the
destructive war of wrath
the valar the guardian spirits of middle
earth raise a giant
star-shaped island out of the ocean as a
gift to the men
who fought against morgoth the island
and the nation that eventually settles
on it
come to define the second age the first
men to settle on the island are led by
their king
elros the brother of elrond due to some
very convoluted family history
the two brothers and their children are
given the choice to live out their lives
as either immortal elves
or mortal men while elrond becomes an
immortal elvish lord
elros becomes the first very mortal king
of numenor where he rules for a little
over 400 years
throughout the second age the island
nation remains a force to be reckoned
with
and a central part of tolkien's
narrative
at the end of the first age the dark
lord morgoth is permanently banished
from middle earth
however many of his servants survive
including the balrog that fights gandalf
in moria and sauron the evil spirit that
would eventually become the lord of the
rings
was the second in command under the dark
lord during the first
age and after morgoth is banished sauron
himself
becomes the dark lord stepping into the
power vacuum left by his master
sauron becomes the main enemy of the
entire second
and third ages roughly a thousand years
into the second age
he establishes mordor as his chief base
of operations
and begins making plans one does not
simply walk into mordor
but we're not talking about sauron the
flaming eyeball here nor about the
towering dude in black armor
at this point in history sauron still
looks pretty good
rather than attacking his elvish enemies
the dark lord capitalizes on his still
attractive physical form
calls himself anatar the lord of gifts
and begins pretending to offer his
friendship to any elves that would
listen to him this side of the misty
mountains
sauron as anatar spends the next few
centuries
worming his way into the affections of
the elves of middle earth
while a few of the elvish lords like
elrond and galadriel
don't trust him most of the rest of the
elves do
one group of elves the same one that
lives near the dwarves and kaza
doom becomes particularly enchanted by
the dark lord in disguise
they're led by a fellow named keller
brimbore and they're famous
for being incredible craftsmen with
anatar's help
they begin to learn how to forge rings
of power
it's at this point that sauron secretly
forges the one
ring he pours a ton of his power into
the ring in order to use it to control
the other rings
when he puts the one ring on though the
elves instantly realize that they've
been duped
and take their rings off in order to
avoid his domination
angry at the fact that his ring gave him
away before he was ready
sauron prepares to subdue the elves the
old-fashioned way
with a war once sauron's real intentions
are revealed
he demands the other rings of power
claiming that the elves
never would have been able to make them
without his help which is technically
true
with the exception of the three elven
rings of course feeling betrayed
the elves refused to hand over any of
their powerful jewelry
with his pretext for war in hand sauron
attacks the free people of middle earth
in a bloody war that lasts for several
years
and nearly leads to the villain's total
domination of the bulk of the continent
initially kelebrimbor and his people are
destroyed
the dwarves retreat to moria and elrond
flees
north to found rivendell the dark lord
also captures the seven rings that
eventually would go to the dwarves
and the nine rings that would eventually
be given to the black riders
critically the three elven rings remain
hidden
just as sauron is preparing to do a
victory lap through middle-earth
the new minorians suddenly arrive
sending the dark lord scampering back to
mordor with little more than a bodyguard
this saves the elves men and dwarves
from total destruction
over the next several centuries the
numenoreans and sauron continued to
build up their strength and
jockey for power and middle-earth sauron
spends the next millennia rebuilding his
strength
he completes his tower of bahra doer the
one where he resides later as a flaming
eye
distributes the rings of power and sets
up the black riders as his terrifying
new servants
he continues to dominate practically
everything in sight
with the crucial exception of the elven
kingdoms he failed to conquer
and a few strong but scattered
settlements of the new minorians along
the coast of middle earth
eventually sauron declares that he is
the king of
men a move that is insulting to the very
manly
certainly unconquered numenoreans the
new minorian king ar farzan the golden
invades middle earth with such a
resplendent army
that sauron's minions abandoned him
without a fight
at this point sauron who still looks
like the attractive anatar
willingly surrenders to the new
minorians and becomes their hostage
this may come across as a cowardly move
on the surface
but it ultimately spells doom for the
new menorians
they bring the dark lord back to their
island nation and it doesn't take long
before the prisoner begins working his
bewitchments on the king himself
once in a position of power sauron
begins convincing the king's subjects to
worship morgoth
complete with human sacrifices
sauron ultimately convinces the king of
numenor to attack the valar
in their land far to the west in a
delusional attempt to gain immortality
this is clearly an issue and it becomes
one of the rare cases in middle earth
history when the supreme
god eru eluvitar himself
comes down to intervene eru destroys the
rebellious king's armada of ships
and sinks the insurgent island in an
atlantis-like catastrophe
interestingly it's at this point in
tolkien's mythology
that the earth is literally reshaped
from a flat plain
to a round sphere sauron himself is
caught in the chaos
and while his spirit survives and heads
back to middle earth
his body is destroyed the second age
narrative tends to revolve mostly around
elves men and their ongoing wars with
sauron however
it's also one of the most prosperous
eras in all of dwarven history
the primary dwarven city in middle earth
at this time is kaza doom
at this point though there isn't a
balrog haunting the mines yet
and the subterranean city is alive with
dwarven life and activity
in addition the city becomes even more
rich and famous after many
talented dwarves from the eastern
dwarven mansions
flee west at the end of the first age
during the second age
the dwarves strike up a particularly
friendly relationship with a neighboring
group of elves
that live right next to their western
gates speak
trend and enter
these are the same elves that end up
making the great rings of power
that the one ring is designed to control
and the two highly skilled races get
along
swimmingly for a long time eventually
when this kingdom of elves is attacked
by sauron
the dwarves will try to help their
friends
unfortunately they come too little and
too late
and end up retreating and locking
themselves up in kaza doom
where they stay out of most of the rest
of the major events of the age
the last two and a half centuries of the
second age focus on the founding of two
important kingdoms
one of which any lord of the rings fans
should recognize
we're talking about arnor and gondor
the two kingdoms founded by a group of
faithful numenoreans who rejected
sauron's silver-tongued lies
and survived the destruction of their
home by sailing away before the
catastrophic chaos erupted
when they arrive in middle-earth they
join forces with the elves
and settle down to a new life these are
the same people that build
among many other things saruman's tower
of orthanc
the city of minas tirith and the tower
at weathertop
they also bring with them the white tree
that can be seen in the return of the
king
as well as the palantiri the shiny
seeing stones that saruman uses to chat
with sauron
everything looks hunky-dory for the two
new kingdoms
until sauron shows up in middle-earth
again
when they realize that sauron has
returned to mordor the exiled
numenoreans named the fiery mountain in
his land mount
doom yes that mount doom not long after
this
sauron begins attacking his enemies yet
again
and the elves men dwarves and all other
free peoples in middle earth
join together to form the last alliance
the initial sequence in the fellowship
of the ring centers on this last
alliance
showing the war in which sauron is
destroyed the ring is
cut from his finger and essildor
tragically refuses to destroy it in the
fires of mount doom
destroy it no
you see dude these moments at the
beginning of the monumental jackson
trilogy
mark the end of the second age not only
does the era dovetail neatly with the
existing cinematic source material
but it leaves a massive helping of epic
stories for the folks at amazon to dig
into check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one